dans l'actu jour d'hui la suite des
échauffourées dans le quartier du bois
de l'étang à la verrière entre des
habitants et les forces de police sept
personnes ont été blessées ce samedi
dont une enfant de 18 mois les résidents
veulent créer un collectif parce que des
échanges naissent la compréhension des
ateliers intergénérationnels sont
proposés entre personnes âgées et
collégiens ils ont travaillé ensemble
autour de textes ce travail sur un
semestre a donné lieu à une restitution
à la maison de la poésie à guyancourt la
revancharde 14e édition c'était ce
dimanche depuis la colline d'elancourt
140 participants étaient inscrits la
course vtt permettait de collecter des
fonds au profit des orphelins des
sapeurs pompiers de paris et puis la
fête de la musique à la batterie de
guyancourt ce samedi une fête placée
sous le signe du rock
une petite fille et cinq policiers
blessés samedi dernier à la verrière
résultat selon différentes sources d'un
affrontement entre jeunes et policiers
d'après les habitants du quartier
rencontrés lundi matin les forces de
l'ordre auraient fait irruption dans un
parc du quartier du bois de l'étang pour
interpeller de façon musclée un jeune
homme la situation est rapidement
dégénéré conséquences toujours selon les
habitants d'une succession d'abus de
longue date de la part de certains
policiers à l'issue de la rixe sept
personnes ont été interpellées et
placées en garde à vue au commissariat
de guyancourt du côté des pouvoirs
publics alain ajaj maire récemment élu
affirme en substance que l'intervention
policière était disproportionnée au
regard de la situation il compte sur la
justice pour faire la lumière sur toute
cette affaire afin de trouver des
solutions pour apaiser les tensions le
préfet a pris la décision de de saisir
la commission départementale de
déontologie qu'une commission
indépendante qui va permettre d'avoir un
avis sur la manière dont les angles les
événements sont déclenchées il ya une
enquête de l'î -p -é jeunes qui va être
déclenchée et aussi donc c'est aussi un
élément pour important pour savoir et
puis enfin il ya le la justice
évidemment qui est saisie d'abord sur
les personnes qui ont été interpellées
puis après sur les éventuelles suites
relatives aux deux autres enquêtes dont
j'ai que j'ai évoqués
lassé par ses rapports conflictuels avec
la police des résidents ont décidé de
s'organiser en collectif et de faire
appel à un avocat objectif mener l
affaire en justice pour faire entendre
leur version de l'événement
ça m'a servi par mon frère qui l'a tapé
ma mère qui marque la ferme emilie
calme-toi lucienne à 87 dont elle parle
comme les jeunes normal
j'avais 14 ans je n'avais pas le choix
de faire des études je devais travailler
je faisais les vendanges roi avant
thomas 14 ans et les racontent une
histoire dont temps encore normal
lucienne thomas mais également japon
huguette delphine ont participé ensemble
un atelier d'expression et d'écriture
permettre à des gens qui sont un peu
d'enfants à qui on tend jamais le micro
les jeunes la marmaille les vieux mais
non mais non
donc cette année non seulement on a eu
envie de leur dire encore plus cette
année car on était en année
présidentielle dans leur dire mais
qu'est ce que vous avez à dire citoyen
cette année indique nous un peu comment
mieux marché cet atelier
intergénérationnel s'est déroulée sur un
semestre et des personnes âgées ont pu
échanger avec des élèves du collège ont
pour vos voisins le bretonneux ce
travail a donné lieu à une restitution à
la maison de la poésie brio
premièrement ça nous fait sortir de chez
nous ont passé un après-midi agréable
les gens qui use en pions dans son
parfait
regardez nous sommes arrivés tout à
l'heure des collégiens qui sont là déjà
sur tous venus nous accueillir ça me
remet un peu dans l'ambiance de l'époque
parce que je suis seul donc ma famille
quand même assez loin j'ai plus de
contacts avec des jeunes là-bas ça
rajeunit un peu et puis leurs
conversations les mots qu'ils emploient
ça vous étonne pas un peu les mots
qu'ils ont il ya des fois il ya un peu
des fans bon dans l'ensemble j'écoute
quand même beaucoup la radio la télé on
arrive est au courant de ce qui se passe
et parle bien
ils ont conscience de beaucoup de choses
j'ai trouvé formidable les voitures dans
la rue bonne journée à s'asseoir bisous
bonjour
puis venu trop tôt je veux à bisous bien
qu'alain j'ai appris à pontoise
sa médaille chimie des je trouvais ça
bien la rencontre entre les toux sèches
je suis un peu moins timide et puis c
c'est bien parce qu'on n'a pas les mêmes
idées on n'a pas aimé nos clients c'est
facile de se confronter avec des idées
différents bon des fois oui des fois non
je trouve cela enrichissant
même époque alors sa chance
ces ateliers intergénérationnels ont été
mis en place pour la troisième année
consécutive cette année des aidants de
l'association veilleurs en voisins ont
également participé la manifestation
s'implante doucement sur le territoire
14e édition de la revancharde sur la
colline d'elancourt c'était ce dimanche
la deuxième manche du challenge vélo
tout-terrain tour 2012 au profit des
orphelins des sapeurs pompiers de france
140 participants se sont élancés sur un
tout nouveau circuit on est sûr vraiment
une épreuve maintenant très très
technique beaucoup plus qu'avant et on a
privilégié un peu le spectacle pour les
familles à chaque tour chaque concurrent
le monde trois fois en haut de la
colline ce qui provoque des meilleures
sensations pour les concurrents et une
meilleure visibilité pour les former
une boucle de 11 km que les vététistes
ont parcouru trois fois et cauterets des
dessins techniques un beau parcours en
perspective j'ai jamais fait de concert
country donc plus
il ya une côte qu'il faudra faire à pied
son dos toilé une côte qui est très
raide que j'ai vu avant donc
psychologiquement je me suis arrêté à
marcher c'est un entraînement et puis
c'est pour avoir une course s'entraîner
au départ et où alain durand g va vous
réparez à cause du bac mais verra bien
et c'est tout vu pour camille galatto
qui s'est imposé chez les femmes chez
les seniors c'est cédric chartier quatre
fois vainqueur de l'épreuve trois mille
euros ont ainsi été récoltés pour les
orphelins des sapeurs pompiers
l'équipe de france de criquets était à
thoiry ce week end pour un match de gala
exceptionnel contre le mardi bonne
cricket club l'instance bicentenaire qui
régit la discipline puisqu'elle détient
les droits de changer ses règles une
occasion à ne surtout pas manquer pour
les internationaux on a deux joueurs qui
sont en congé sans solde comme ces
amateurs ils ont pris des congés en plus
on les a joués dans le match en 2005
vous savez était un un don classés ils
viennent pour la revanche donc à nous de
montrer qu'on perdra patients de terre
une histoire particulière entoure cette
rencontre le cric et n'ayant été qu'une
seule fois inscrit aux jeux olympiques
ceux de paris en 1900 elle opposait
alors deux équipes l'angleterre et la
france ce match s'inscrit dans une
commémoration des jeux olympiques de
paris de 1900 jeux olympiques de paris
de 1900 le cricket et et sports
olympiques c'est donc une célébration de
ce match au cours desquelles
l'angleterre avait battu la france et
donc la france est aujourd'hui encore
détentrice d'une médaille d'argent jeux
olympiques en cricket revanchards les
anglais avaient à coeur de défier les
français le niveau n'est pas le même
mais il resté méfiant vis-à-vis des
internationaux
graff
et commence à devenir bon le criquet
n'est pas présent depuis longtemps ici
mais ça se développe doucement et ce
qu'on a pu voir jusque là leur
préparation et leur entraînement en
tenue officielle ils seront difficiles à
jouer
des enfants ont pu s'essayer à ce sport
britannique les règles n'étant pas
toujours simple et la discipline peu
connue en france il s'agissait avant
tout de réussir des bases quand on
attrape et les balles chaque fois que
les baleines est là les verts pas vers
le haut j'arrive à les attraper et
heureux me disais que c'était viable
des supporters ravis qu'ils ont fait
signer des autographes mais
malheureusement les français se sont
inclinés
ambiance jazz ambiance groovy ambiance
funky ce soir à la batterie alors c'est
pas mal en guise d'introduction mais moi
je vous propose de passer tout de suite
à quelque chose de beaucoup plus
rock'n'roll le rock'n'roll c'est
justement le thème qu'a choisi et je
regarde bien et son équipe pour fêter la
musique et pour faire leur fête de la
musique en décalé alors pourquoi le
choix de ce thème usé la question
c'est parti
il
parce que le groupe qui répète ici dans
nos studios sont majoritairement du
groupe pop rock
après quelque 20% évidemment ça se
ressent sur les plateaux quand paul on
propose ce soir et âme tu veux tu joues
beaucoup de classiques rock j'ai un peu
pop rock aussi sa dépense et des
générations feront toujours amant aussi
dans nos studios toutes sortes de
génération donc
maintenant très anciens voilà la mode
fait aussi son anniversaire aujourd'hui
voilà m
autant de styles que d'interprète et
quand on demande aux spectateurs si le
roc leur évoque quelque chose chacun y
va de sa référente hendrix
zep plutôt dans les années 60-70
de la musique qui bouge la musique avec
beaucoup d'instruments et la guitare
électrique
ces lycées metallica volbeat les beatles
simple tour l'ex ange aussi pour moi
parce que je suis pas une adepte
particulièrement de cette musique c'est
plutôt une époque
les années 70 la grande liberté
les barrières pour fit tomber et tout ça
ouais bon je pense que ça a le mérite
d'être clair en tout cas quel que soit
le style l'origine ou l'interprète les
spectateurs présents samedi soir à la
batterie ont eu l'occasion de s'en
mettre plein les oreilles écoutez
là
je pars
et